the economy and the troubling sign for
home buyers the average interest rate
for a 30-year fixed mortgage is higher
than it's been in 21 years
7.16 percent mortgage rates are
influenced by the Federal Reserve which
is expected to increase its interest
rates again to fight inflation this
morning Nancy Chen looks at the impact
on families Nancy good morning good to
see you Nate good morning to you those
High rates are sending both buyers and
sellers into mortgage sticker shock as
affordability is still a major challenge
for many navigating this Market
right is it hiding in your shirt oh my
Jessica and Jackie fasolino have been
searching for a house to call their own
in northern New Jersey how much has the
housing market changed during your
search immensely it's it's you can't
even compare
after being repeatedly outbid last year
the fascinos are now being priced out
because of soaring interest rates we
want to have that home that we can call
home that is ours or isn't that the
American dream you know do you feel like
that's being taken away from you a bit
rates have more than doubled since the
start of the year with the most popular
home loan hitting an average rate of
7.16 percent this week for the first
time since 2001. that's the fastest
they've grown on record cooling a red
hot housing market I think that we've
been going through a correction interest
rates were low for the whole entire
pandemic and that created a bit of a
frenzy in the housing market a mortgage
payment on a median priced home stands
at about twenty five hundred dollars a
month that's about 750 dollars more than
the start of the year how high could
these rates go the FED likely isn't
going to reverse course until they see
really strong conclusive evidence that
inflation is turning around for now
mortgage applications are down 42
percent from this time last year as both
buyers and sellers play the waiting game
the fastolinos say they'll stay in their
apartment and start their search again
next year
we just are ready for that home that
we've always kind of seen ourselves
having which will be someday just not
today
while we were told that mortgage
interest rates probably won't drop until
late next year there are opportunities
in all of this experts tell us buyers
should check with multiple lenders and
assemble the right team so you're ready
when the opportunity does come up Gail
all right got it Nancy thank you